[Music]
with sci-fi adventure in a cast of
cosmic misfits that includes a talking
raccoon and his best friend
a tree it's no surprise that marvel's
guardians of the galaxy was a big hit
for kids when it hit theaters
all the adults who saw it however might
have noticed a few other things that
flew
right over the younger viewers heads
destination earth
even though he was taken from earth as a
child and raised among the outlaws known
as the ravagers
one of the key components of peter
quill's character is his intense
connection to his homeworld
it's exemplified through the awesome mix
cassette tape given to him by his mother
before she died
which he listens to non-stop to form the
film's soundtrack
when we see peter as an adult it's been
26 years since he was abducted into
space by the ravagers and he's still
holding onto the mixtape
his backpack a troll doll and the few
other mementos he has of his old home
he's also a capable pilot who knows his
way around the galaxy and even has his
own spaceship named after the decidedly
earth-based celebrity alyssa milano
so he definitely tried to go back to
earth at some point right
maybe not recently since he seems to
have settled into the life of a
space-faring outlaw
but it's hard to imagine a universe in
which star-lord didn't run away from the
ravagers and head back home at the first
chance he got even if it was just to see
if the jackson 5 ever put out another
song
unfortunately that's not a story we've
ever seen unless he spent a few years
undercover in pawnee indiana
there's only one man for the job bert
macklin
tale of the tape peter's trusty walkman
and the mixtape contained within it are
more than just a playlist
it's his main attachment to the memory
of his mother and it became the
essential hallmark of the film too
it's embedded in the very fabric of the
guardians of the galaxy franchise
so much so that when he has to escape
from space prison peter risks his life
and his freedom just to get the tape
back
and it also represents a genuine miracle
in audio preservation technology
as anyone who is actually around in the
80s knows
cassette tapes aren't exactly the most
durable format especially if you're
playing them over and over for say
26 years and yet peter's mixtape and the
walkman he uses to play it are in
perfect working condition after being
bounced around the universe for a
quarter of a century
and that's not the only tape tech peter
has either sony has a repair tech in
nowhere
or peter just happened to run into the
only member of the nova corps who could
hook him up with a tape deck pulled
straight out of the dashboard of a
custom van
zero g when the team is taken to the
kiln prison it's up to rocket to come up
with a way to get out
and what he comes up with actually ends
up working pretty well
the escape plan hinges on the team
getting up into the guard tower
turning off the artificial gravity in
the prison and then simply flying away
it's a good idea but it also involves at
least one very large
chunk of luck for some reason when the
artificial gravity goes off the kiln
guards
many of whom had previously been holding
riot shields and rocket launchers
just start madly flailing around as they
float not only do they never recover as
the guardians make their escape
they also drop their weapons obviously
suddenly losing gravity would have an
element of surprise
but if you're going to build a super
secure prison in the depths of space
you'd think training your guards to
fight in 0g would be one of the first
things you'd do
the second thing telling them not to
drop their guns at the first sign of
trouble
the ravager diet peter is abducted from
earth as a boy by the ravagers
a group of outlaws with their own code
and system of command who were hired by
peter's still mysterious father to bring
him back
yondu the leader of this particular
faction of ravagers decides to keep
peter and raise him like a murderous
outer space mary poppins
rather than dosing his medicine with a
spoonful of sugar though
yondu keeps young peter in line by
reminding him that he saved him more
than once from being eaten by his fellow
ravagers
they seem pretty eager to find out what
creatures from this distant planet
called earth taste like
when i picked you up on terror these
boys of mine wanted to eat
yeah they never tasted any tearing
before i stopped them
so are ravagers space cannibals or do
they just consider human beings to be
livestock
they're made up of all manner of alien
species so if they were that willing to
drop a clearly cinchy and peter quill
onto their plates at lunchtime
have they also eaten members of each
other species too
that can make for some pretty awkward
conversation around the table but the
movie never bothers to answer this
question
even though we're hungry for answers
love and the single alien
star-lord definitely fits into the
lovable scoundrel category
and apparently that includes all
definitions of lovable
he apparently has a tendency toward
meaningless flings with all manner of
alien species
he has a woman whose name he's forgotten
in his ship when we first meet him
he hits on gamora when he sees her and
later he tells drax various stories
about alien women who've attacked him
after he romanced his way out of
and into plenty of trouble if you've
ever watched star trek and seen captain
kirk's attitude towards the prime
directive when it comes to green women
you already know this isn't exactly a
new element for sci-fi
still we have to ask do all
humanoid-looking aliens have compatible
reproductive organs
the only elaboration we get from peter
is a story about flirting with a woman
who had tentacles and needles for teeth
he says he only spent time with her in a
quest for information but what would
have happened if he'd taken that
interaction to the next level
maybe we're better off not knowing lazy
lazy thanos
after avengers infinity war we all know
thanos is a super villain who could be
not just a mastermind
but a punishing and relentless force
before infinity war though his major
abilities seem less built around
fist-fighting gods
and more about delegating tasks to
lesser villains
this is especially evident in guardians
of the galaxy as he did in the avengers
thanos sends someone else ronin the
accuser to obtain
an infinity stone for him rather than
doing anything himself he spends all of
his time seated on a floating throne in
space
hurling threats and giving orders but
never actually showing the audience why
he's so dangerous
it definitely works in the context of
the larger mcu
but if you were to watch this film on
its own you'd essentially just be taking
everyone at their word that thanos is a
bad dude
here he's basically a guy who tells
everyone else to go do something for him
while he kicks back and gets irritated
when they fail no wonder ronan decided
to strike out on his own when he
realized he had an infinity stone in his
possession
mint condition when the guardians
realize they need to get rid of the orb
before it falls into the wrong hands
gamora's plan is to sell it to the
collector an ancient and powerful being
who
well collects things if they give it to
him she reasons they can both no longer
be responsible for it
and get paid the collector is happy to
oblige
but while the group is in his home he
notices something else he'd like to buy
groot you must allow me to pay you now
so that i may own your caucus
at the moment of your death of course
while it's certainly nice of him to pay
upfront and wait for group to live a
full life
the film also makes it pretty clear that
the collector has no such scruples about
other specimens in his collection
numerous living seemingly sentient
things are visible in his display cases
including marvel's own cosmo the space
dog and howard the duck
here's hoping they were offered a better
deal than the one groot was going to get
you know how to whistle don't you of all
the interesting space technology on
display in guardians of the galaxy
there's nothing more intriguing than
yondu's yaka arrow
lifted straight from the comic page the
incredible sharp and fast weapon is
controlled through whistling and a
technological
fin on yondu's head and it's powerful
enough to slaughter a whole group of
enemies with a simple melody
it's a neat piece of gear and while it's
certainly very effective in its current
form
it's hard to watch the yaka arrow in
action and wonder why yondu
isn't thinking bigger sure the arrow is
elegant but what about a rocket launcher
that works the same way
or a drone or a whole ship perhaps it
requires more mental energy and control
than yondu's whistle can summon
or maybe it's just limited by being in
range of the whistle sound
meaning that he couldn't fly the arrow
through the silent depths of space
but it seems like they might be shooting
pretty low even though it's remarkably
effective
you